[Musica]
buonasera a tutti
wow quanti siete mi fate quasi paura
credo che prima di parlarvi del mio
progetto quello che mi ha portato qui
davanti a voi questa sera io e debba
prima spiegarvi un pochino chi sono io
negli innumerevoli colloqui di lavoro
che affrontato nella mia vita come credo
tutti voi qui in questa sala alla
terribile domanda mi 10 un pregio e un
difetto trovavo sempre tantissimi
difetti e mai un pregio
niente che mi descrivesse che mi
caratterizza severamente per quello che
ero nel mio ultimissimo colloquio di
lavoro quello per l'assunzione
definitiva in una grande catena di
librerie dove lavoravo da anni alla
domanda del mio area manager
aderisci la filosofia aziendale
ho preso un po di coraggio e ho risposto
no non aderisco questo perché il modello
di business
secondo il quale un libro deve essere
venduto come se fosse un paio di scarpe
una giacca un paio di calzini non mi
apparteneva
ero fermamente convinta del fatto che
chi frequenta una libreria non lo fa per
acquistare un oggetto cerca
un'esperienza diversa cerca un rapporto
innanzitutto con la persona che ha
davanti in carne ed ossa e poi con i
personaggi che sono contenuti nei testi
ovviamente il contratto non mi è stato
rinnovato non ho capito sinceramente
come mai però ringraziato ho salutato
perché dall esperienza ho imparato
tantissimo ho notato come le persone
chiedessero consiglio quasi sempre in
base ai loro stati emotivi cercavano un
libro per l'amico che sarah appena
lasciato ed era in crisi un libro magari
per qualcuno che ha perso il lavoro o
libro per se stessi che magari stavano
passando un momento un pochino un
pochino no e volevano tirarsi su di
morale
le casistiche che io ascoltato in questi
anni in libreria erano veramente le più
svariate
ho ascoltato attentamente ho preso un
altro pochino di coraggio e ho deciso di
lanciare un mio modello di libreria
basata sulle mozioni una cosa che non
esisteva una farmacia letteraria per
l'esattezza quando ho deciso di
intraprendere questa strada mi sono
confrontato avviamento
con amici parenti conoscenti quando
dicevo loro guarda io voglio aprire una
libreria le persone mi guardavano come
se fossi una pazza scappata da un
manicomio vincevano nel 2018 una
libreria ma vedi che chiudono ma sei
sicura come dare così controcorrente
io ho cercato un altro pezzettino di
coraggio dentro di me e sono andata
avanti
c'erano due problemi principali in cui
nella strutturazione nel mio progetto
innanzitutto io devo cercare un catalogo
letterario basato totalmente sulle
emozioni per partire mi sono basato
ovviamente dalla cosa più semplice
quindi dalla mia esperienza di lettrice
pluriennale ho cercato di ricordare
tutti i testi che mi avevano aiutato nei
momenti terribili della mia vita nei
momenti difficili quando magari mi
sentivo veramente persa
oppure anche testi un pochino più
semplici per i quali meno fatte magari
quattro risate in giornate nelle quali
non mi sarei voluto alzare dal letto
avrei voluto dormire sotto il piumone
tutto il giorno mi servirà però
ovviamente un approccio professionale e
psicologico per per fondare questa mia
libreria
ho chiamato mia sorella una delle più
care amiche due psicologhe
professioniste e ho detto loro benissimo
nella società chiamo un tavolo
esaminiamo tutti i testi che abbiamo
letto nella nostra vita
e voi mi dite vi racconto cosa succede e
delle caratteristiche voi mi dite in che
categoria di stato emotivo è stato
esistenziale atteggiamento possiamo
classificarli abbiamo esaminato
centinaia di testi li abbiamo inseriti
alcuni ne abbiamo esclusi altri si
poneva però un ulteriore problema come
fare a comunicare al lettore a chi si
approccia questo testo quale emozioni
sono contenute
ho ideato quindi dei piccoli dei piccoli
tag che ho chiamato bugiardini nei quali
sono contenute indicazioni e la
posologia e gli effetti collaterali
ho scelto questo nome proprio per dare
un messaggio chiaro e diretto a chi si
approcciava al testo il libro è un'opera
d'arte e come tale cura ha un effetto
benefico sulla nostra anima i bugiardini
sono semplicemente delle piccole mappe
concettuali sono poche frasi che però
possono dare un'idea al lettore
e possono più che altro farlo agire
anche in autonomia senza magari un
giudizio di merito un intermediario di
un'altra persona quindi trovare proprio
delle situazioni all'interno dei libri
che noi stessi abbiamo vissuto in prima
persona però nei testi non siamo noi
sono degli altri quindi possiamo trovare
anche dei nuovi approcci delle nuove di
nuovi spunti di riflessione è se non è
proprio questo il grandissimo potere
della cultura farci cambiare idea
prospettiva punto di vista farci andare
dentro di noi in profondità fa comunque
cercare un senso più profondo di noi del
mondo e ci rende più tolleranti anche
nei confronti degli altri ci fa proprio
capire anche un punto di vista diverso
dal nostro
guardare chi abbiamo di fronte e
fermarci ascoltarlo veramente per quello
che ha da dirci non magari relazioni
superficiali proprio fermarsi ed
ascoltare il mio progetto alla fine è
tutto qua è molto molto semplice io
ascolto le persone sono basate
totalmente sul rapporto di condivisione
un rapporto umano però riportare diciamo
il linguaggio su quello che è il
linguaggio universale delle emozioni ci
fa si fa scavalcare queste barriere che
possono essere date dalla cultura e
riporta la lettura ad essere il
territorio di tutti il libro la lettura
essere il territorio di tutti tantissime
persone che vengono da me in libreria mi
dicono guarda io non leggo libri da anni
e mai librio mi sono mai interessati
però visto questa tua cosa mi dai un
libro voglio iniziare a leggere riescono
proprio a capire l'importanza che la
cultura ha nella vita di tutti gli
esseri umani empatizzare creare
condivisioni con situazioni nelle quali
magari noi ci troviamo ma non sappiamo
come uscirne
per capire magari che anche se noi sono
impossibile ce la caveremo ce la potremo
fare
e io stessa che sono qui davanti a voi a
parlare oggi veramente posso dirvi che
per quanto nella vita può essere tutto
nero vi sentite finiti alla fine delle
risorse dentro di voi le potete trovare
sempre e comunque questo proprio
messaggio che mi preme è dare oggi che
comunque nella vita ci sono dei momenti
nei quali ci sentiamo persi
però alla fine ce la possiamo fare ecco
se mai dovessi ri approcciarmi un
colloquio di lavoro spero mai nel
momento in cui mi chiederanno un mio
pregio saprò come finalmente cosa
rispondere il coraggio
[Applauso]
[Musica]